[音楽]
ana
ん
ています
突然ですが皆さんに質問があります
この中で
正しい閉会地図はどれでしょうか
ちょっと実際に行け上げていただきたいと思いますはじめに a だと思うからっ
b だと思うかだ
はい
最後に椎名と思うから
はいありがとうございます
正解は b
しかし小学生の頃の僕
未だ c が焦点に食っての世界地図は
シーサ
ちなみに行こう消費秋社会の点数は80点ぐらいかあっはぁれシイラ消費青い制作して
先
僕がどんな子供だったが皆さんに紹介させてください
単撃に言うと僕は変わった子供でした
昆虫採集と石集めが大好きで
ヒマさえあれば公園に行きブースト石をよく集めていました
昆虫図鑑や鉱物図鑑を眺めることにはさほど興味はありませんでした
車
確かに図鑑はページを上げくれば熱いなが公園の中を動き回るなくても牛や医師の写真
や名前をごまんといることができます
便利ですよねー
ではそのペラペラの鍵がいい
例えばこのクワガタっ
平川かっていうのですが
かまれると鳥くらいタイプ
わかりますか
分かりません
ちなみに来いく球れるとかなり痛いです
このようにペラペラの紙の集合体から分かることには限界があるし実用性も高くあり
ません
つまり結論から言うと僕は自分の目で見て確かめたものしか信じないというものだった
のです
つまり平たく県が噛むと痛いということだけではなくて
ヒラタクワガタの存在ついたいっ
自分の上で実際に目にするまたは自分で捕まえるまでは信じられない子どもだったの
です
図鑑のように他者によって集められた情報というのは僕にとってあくまで
自分の目でたしかめ
退勤するためのツールでしかないという認識で車
よって
小学生の頃の僕は生まれてこのかた
鹿児島県でたことがなかったのでお気にどっちの世界一部がこれだか
というわけです
図にするとこんな感じですからねうんうんっ
ああああああ
ではこんな子供を育てるにあたって誰が一番苦労するっていう
それはもちろんよろしいんですね
しかし僕の両親は
こういった僕の好奇心の実現に対して非常に協力的でした
一つ今でもよく覚えているのが石ころが大好きな彼
c が少年が2万円のクリスタジェット目立ったときのことです
シイラ少年は偶然に世間にかけたその
ただの石ころセットに非常に心を惹かれていました
僕が親であれば100円ぐらいの愛でを買ってた回してもらうところなのですが
その時奥の両親は将来は医師が博士になるでへと
心よくなってくれますか
僕の過程は決して裕福ではありませんでした
しかしそんな環境にありながらも僕のそういった考えを尊重し支えてくれる両親のこと
を育ったおかげで僕は自分で確かめたものこそ信じるに値する
という考えにも度経験を積み重ねてきました
ん
そしてそこから五弾経験地としての学びはすべてこれまでの自分の人生を豊かにして
いきたいと感じています
皆さんを刺しかと思いますは経験値こそ信じるに値するというスタンスのまま
多くは成長し大学生になりました
大学1年生の時
初めて海外に行けば
ベイト中でふ
確かに地理の教科書にはベトナムというふうには描かれていましたが僕は実際に行った
ことがなかったので教科書の情報をうのみにするわけもなく
教科書に書かれている国等はあくまで軽いものの情報という認識でした
しかしこの借り物の情報が
経験値変化したとき多くの中の価値観にちょっとした変化が起こりまして
それまでは自分の中の世界一部に鹿児島しか存在していないことに対してさほど問題
意識を持っていなかったのですが
実際にベトナムに降り立ち日本では確実に得ることのできない経験値を患者数
発覚しました
そして僕は自分の中の世界一部に確かに
ベトナムを書き込むと同時に
k 現地により自分の中の世界へ地図を広げることの大切さを強く感じました
自分の取り合わなかったものの5位が数字つ後にはなくなれなんて経験
鹿児島では起こりえません
もちろん環境のすべてではありませんか
自分で実際に様々な家を訪れ自分だけの経験を積み重ねること
これまでも常に使っていますが自分の中の地図を広げるということは経験値の中でも
非常に多くの学びを与えてくれると感じました
そこから僕は積極的に自分の中の地図を広げていきました
そしてこのまず4強の中の世界沈んはアメリカが書き込まれます
そしてそこからさほど遠くない障害
僕の中の世界実は宇宙人になる
いや宇宙自分にする予定です
思いつきで言っているわけではなく真剣です
ウチュウをこの目で確かめたいんです
大抵の人の場合
宇宙いくというのは単なる夢やあこがれで終わる場合がほとんどだと思います
しかし僕はそのほとんど一緒ではありません
この夏アメリカで宇宙工学を成功していきます
自分の毛で有人宇宙ロケットを作りたいからです
非常に挑戦的な試みであることは自覚しています
ですがこれまで僕が獲得したどの経験値の中でもそれが全く不可能であるというのは
書いていません
僕はこのアイディアで政府と美建留学 japan に採用され来月8月から1年間
アメリカで宇宙工学を専攻していきます
自分が長くちず丸どんどん広がっていく未来に期待でいっぱいです
インターネットが普及したさっこ
大抵のことはクリック一つで調べることができます
[音楽]
宇宙の写真や動画などこの頃あふれています
足それらはあくまで誰か経験によって得られた
借り物の知識に過ぎません
自分の体験によって得た経験値と比べて実践力に欠けますし生きた自意識にはなり
にくいのではないでしょうか
ネット社会に生きる僕たちにはこの経験値が圧倒的に不足しています
などで皆さんも自分だけの経験を積み重ねて自分の地図を広げてほしいと考えています
そして僕が描きたいチーズの中には宇宙がありましたが
自分のあり方は人それぞれで
一条ではないと思います
皆さんを自分だけの地図を広げてください
ありがとうございましたはぁ
[拍手]